Watch this one.
See here. So, we're on top and yes, you
can control from there, but we want to
be there. Okay, Sean, your team and your
dog Sean.
When's the center move? At the end.
Okay,
try it again.
Now we go wide. Well, why is because I'm
not touching the center from the palm at
the wrist. Okay.
And I got to get to the outside. So,
let's go back and do some other things
in there.
Um, don't try to
Okay,
we did this drill, right, where I I
touch, I press into him, and then I
would move his center. Remember that or
pull pull his center, too. Pull his
center. From there, we did it with open
hands and we did it with fingertips
cross.
Let's say
that bouquet starts to has like a crappy
grip. Do you understand? So let's say I
go here and they are like peeling what
is touching any part that's touching
you.
Do you understand that? Okay. So here
again we have I say we make a fetish out
of the form.
Um or we make a fetish out of I get
stuck on one thing.
Whenever I'm I have my job for me. He'll
drive like prescribed. Okay. Let's say
he he will not get his elbow
while I still use the thumb.
You get see what I'm talking about.
Okay. So, same thing. I'm here like
that. You feel the grip loosen. I'm
going to reach for you and get the grip.
I get the grip and I still get over
there. Okay. Try it again.
Don't chase the form. Taste the feeling.
chase the feeling. So,
let's try to You're in the middle. Your
team's in the middle.
Same side.
That's the difference. Same side. Good.
Okay. Now, what do you feel already? Be
honest. all emotion. I know what you
feel. So, you're just not you're not
sharing a secret.
Rio. He keeps making
this hard on me. You You got it. Okay.
So, we have to figure out how am I going
to do this. It's a yin-yang world. Okay.
Let's see what
this guy keeps making it hard or
whatever. You know, this is a with
Rio. I was doing it the other. Okay.
Okay. Got it. Whatever.
Better.
There's the There's the frustration.
Better. Good. Okay. So, what do you
think you're doing different now? What
makes your teacher say good?
All right.
So again, if we're doing keyhon
we are we are more towards the
application phase which means we're not
purely energetic. We're not purely in
those energetic cultivation processes.
Is everyone understand? So in the
energetic fields
I want to get rid of the external stuff
as much as possible because it can
achieve the same ends. Do do you
understand? But just like the ego
tripartite mind I'm not trying to get
rid of it. I can't get rid of it. How
would that be a harmony of yin and yang?
Okay. Well yes in some taichi circles
don't don't move your body. And then
what did they say? And then they don't
move their feet either. Okay, we're
going to move. We're going to combine
both external and internal. And it's a
fluctuation based on your skill set. So
um let's say she's she's very light.
I don't need to take any mechanical
pressure off of her. You light. Okay.
But let's say, that keeps going
that way. You know what I mean? Because
you're so strong. You want to turn it.
And it takes off your mechanical
ability. Do you understand? But as I'm
turning it, I'll be whatever my Poke
ability is. Let's say it's 10, but
you're pushing at 12. Do you understand?
They're like, "Fuck it. I'm going to
lose it." Okay. I I go like this. Well,
now you're pushing at
10. You got it. And now and I I find it.
So I just do it seamlessly and no one
you you can't tell, but I'm fluctuating
between the two. Okay? And that is the
arc. That is the key. That that's
exactly what you do. You don't sit still
and and just try to coeue everyone all
over the place. Okay? So if you're
feeling like a lot of
but what you're not doing is this.
You never touch the center. Okay. All
right. Try it.
Don't take him to your right. Make him
fall to the to his
right.
Let your thumb lead. Let your thumb
lead. Not your palm. Your palm doesn't
leave.
Let your thumb lead. Take pressure off
quickly. compromising your base.
Touch the center as you can. Yes.
Thumb leads.
Is that pinky off of her thumb? Thumb.
Thumb. Thumb. Chris, turn your thumb.
Yes.
Start turning the thumb over. Turn it
over. There you go. Touch the center as
you're going. Well, whatever fingertips
are there, touch the center through the
fingertips.
Your elbow's coming out. Try it again.
Touch the center. Go to the form.
Turn your thumb. Turn your thumb. Turn
your thumb. Turn your thumb. Turn your
thumb
and touch the center. Turn your thumb.
Change partners.
Turn your thumb.
Use fingertips, palms, your wrist,
anything. You touch the center through
your L and the thumb is your metric.
Turn your thumb. Turn your thumb.
Turning your thumb. Find the center.
Thumb. Turn your thumb.
I don't know what's going on there.
This is the shade. This is the shape.
Boom. Boom. Boom. This is not the shape.
You see how different that looks? Okay.
Yes, I can do it.
I want you to do the shape.
Don't want you to do I
try it again.
Good.
Start to feel the torque that's coming
into your ton dead with this elbow
movement.
Turn your thumb. Turn it down. Turn your
thumb. The thumb leads. The thumb leads.
Lift. The thumb leads.
That's all I do.
Let's look at what happens to his body.
The angle is more.
The foot knee ball is out of alignment.
The loud elbow shoulder is out of
alignment. You see that? You add the
inertia whenever he's going that way.
Will you Will you lean that way a little
bit that way? That way. This is perfect
for right. Wait till ready. Okay. And
you go.
Do you understand? So you do the other
one.
Okay. We want to get him rotating. There
he is.
Okay. So do the shape because it does
different things to his body. Does
different things into you too. Okay. But
let's look at his body. Okay. Go.
Get his elbow out of alignment.
Get his knee qual out of alignment.
Okay, this I check
it. But do it from the beginning.
start speeding up when you touch the
center. If if you're having to do
mechanical attendance,
I don't turn him. I know he turns. I
know he's turning, but I'm not turning
him. Do you understand? I do that. I
don't go turn him. Okay.
Always
touching the center. Getting out of his
joints.
Don't go back.
All right. So, let's look now at
something I've been doing.
I have at the beginning I have my elbow
foot
long line.
Let's look at the shoulder grid. That
should outer rim, the outer shoulder,
that's my yong line. You draw a straight
line down my shoulder.
My yin line is halfway
through half chest. Everyone with me?
Okay. And then the middle, neither this
nor that. That I call the Wuji line.
I'm going to take
the elbow and the elbow will go to the
yin line. Cannot go past it. You go past
it, you're going to lose what we want
energetically and you're going to lose
what we want marshally.
The elbow can only go to the yin
or to the yang. That is it.
The wrist can go to the boutique.
So elbow and the wrist is at the bi.
When you come back out like that, you're
going to do outer del. Okay? So I never
go
this way.
If you want your wrist back, you have to
undo it or go outer spiral.
You see that? And when you go outer
spiral, it'll drop back this way. The
elbow stays on the in line, but the
wrist can go out. Okay. Now, if you
watch my elbows, this is going to give
you your anchored elbows the whole time
where we're more powerful from there
than moving out here distally. So, the
elbow moves the wrist.
The elbow moves the wrist. I'm not doing
this stuff. The elbow never came off the
shoulder line. Okay, does that make
sense? All right. So, I I understand
you're like, smell it, but you smelling
it and going outer deltoid. Don't do it.
If he's bigger, it'll be harder. Okay,
you already got everything you need. So,
it's just
here. Elbow's doing it. Elbow's doing
it. Elbow's doing it. Elbows doing it.
stayed on the line. Okay, try it again.
Elbow power.
Elbow power. That was day one. Elbow
power.
Yes. Don't let your elbow go past that
line. Don't let your elbow go past the
end line.
Picture
the grid on your chest. Picture your
elbows.
Spiral rotating in space. Keep going.
Pack.
Okay. Um,
go back to day one. Yes, the elbow
power. But what powers the elbow?
The quad. Okay.
So, remember I had
Okay. Um,
you want to move your elbows face, you
move the claw.
Don't do what we were doing. You're
going to do what we were doing up here,
but the
is going to get much easier.
What? Again, though,
what's wrong? I turn my back and all the
way out of alignment. It doesn't take
much. The ball doesn't move much.
Okay, try it.
You still got to touch the center. You
still got a ground vector.
The claw moves. The claw moves the
elbow.
That's your elbow moving. The quad boost
the elbow.
Don't let your elbow go up. Hey,
that's it.
Don't ask so much that you get an
unnatural posture and tension back in
your body.
Quack quack quack quack quack quack.
All right. So, let me let me give you
something. Sure. All right.
If the claw move the elbow, tell me
what's wrong with this.
move. Yeah, the hand is moving before
that claw's moving. No, the problem is
with the hand.
Touch your center, cloud. Touch your
center, move the
finding in space in her angle that I'm
generating the moves.
Okay, try it.
Keep the shape of the hands. Go around
their arm.
Keep the shape of your hands.
Keep laan. Fingers are spread.
Thug is down.
Follow the yin-yang grid. Don't go past
Wuji on the wrist.
Turn this thumb down. Turn this one
down.
Turn this thumb down.
Better. Yes.
Turn the thumb without lifting the
elbow.
Yes. There you go. And not too far that
it takes you out of alignment.
Turn this up. Fix your hand first. B on.
Go around them.
Keep your fingers displayed. Go around.
Thumb goes around. Yes. Good. Good. Keep
turning it with the claw. That's it.
Yes.
Swing the claw. There he is. Right
there.
[Music]
So here we had friction from the from
the inertia going forward. If he's going
in a circle,
there's centrifugal energy and that's
what I'm using on the adhesion. It's now
on this this hand. So I'm not grabbing
him or anything like that. I'm just
here.
You feel the stick? Hi.
I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. You
won't like it.
See how different that is. Okay. Right.
Until you hear it. Stop. Okay. So, here.
And I'm just
[Music]
Okay. Try it.
I'm passing him from one control hand to
the other control hand.
Keep it going. You're using the
centrifugal energy so he can't stop.
Yes. Yes.
Get it moving.
You can't stop. Nice.
Get him moving. Keep them moving.
Yes.
Keep her moving. Keep her moving. Keep
her moving. Don't pull.
Look.
Don't
Don't pull him. I know you smell the
backwards. And so you want you want to
like pull him backwards. Do you see
that?
Go ahead and go that way. I I'm on this
side.
Do you see that difference? So, uh, a
lot of times when when you're over here
like that, you're going to pull
backwards. You can actually pull the
athlete back into their base.
So, you just keep it moving. In this
drill, all we're doing is I keep it
moving on. I'm on this side, making it
stronger. So, you can feel that it's on
it's on the outside. I keep pressing
against it. Okay? Like a ride. You know
that ride where you go and you're like
stuck on the on the wall. That's exactly
what his head is stuck on my hand. Okay.
As long as I don't tense and I just stay
there and match it, it will stick on my
hand. Okay. Try it.
Thumb.
You got to get You got to get over here.
See the gravity.
I think you're on the wrong side. You're
doing
We're on the other side.
Feel that pressure against the inside of
your hand.
Yeah,
you got to keep it moving.
You're on the back as he starts to turn
him. Okay.
That's where Tristan That's where
Tristan all he's like, I don't know what
you want, so but I don't do anything.
And then he's standing up again on you.
Okay.
Yes. Yes.
You got to He has to move this way. So
why? Okay, think about it this way.
Imagine
that you were on that ride and the
centrical energy had you stuck to the
side of the wall. Does everyone know the
ride I'm talking about? Anyone not seen
that ride?
Okay.
Okay. Um, imagine if the ride could
immediately stop.
Would you stay stuck to the wall? No.
No. The inertia would keep you going for
a little bit, but you'd be coming off
the wall. Okay. a batch of the ride was
stopped,
right?
And um
would you ever get stuck to the wall?
No. The ride to start, nobody's stuck to
the wall. Okay. So again, one of my main
criticisms is that the stopping and
starting that we see all the time in
modern video after video, stopping,
starting, they're not using the what I
just will generally for now call
gravity. This is probably inertia,
centrifugal force, whatever. They're not
using the force. They're using the
materiality, the anatomy of the guy.
Okay, you guys understand? So that force
is present. That force is present even
with me not moving. The force is present
as long so that means that I could do it
very slowly and he'll feel the friction.
Okay, you got it. But if I am here and I
stop, that's different. That's
different. And this is where the guy
that's fighting you just
Okay, got it. So, no matter how slow you
go, he has to keep moving. Okay, try it.
I know that for a fact. And you do, too.
That means you have to get him to start
moving.
Yes. Keep moving.
Yeah, you got to be to the outside of
the cential force.
He stops ever so slightly.
It goes off and on as you step you the
radius. So here, watch for a second.
When you're here like this,
he's he is going
I have to generate the equal yang. Okay.
So I mean I I could do it here with my
body which I prefer. I don't prefer that
I'm in close and I do it with my bicep.
Okay. So I'm here like this. We're going
there it is. But as I step you see my
elbow's going closer to him and off of
him. And so the pressure is going on and
off.
So you got to be careful where you step.
So I can't tell you where you step, but
I can tell you did you feel it go on and
off? Okay. So make sure it doesn't go on
and off because your cooperative boot
can't fall for you cuz Yeah. Okay. But
we're chasing the feeling, not whether
he fell or not. Okay. Try it again.
There's the other way.
Taste butter.
That's better.
Got to get it moving. You got to
generate the senses before.
Okay. Look at the shape of my hand.
Okay. Watch the shape of my hand.
I'll do two. I'll do two versions. I'll
go slow. Still feel it.
What would you say is the difference in
the shape of my hand? One's like a soft
cup and one's a clo now. One one is
trying to to grab. Okay. So, I know if
you're grabbing, you're not feeling what
I need you to feel. Okay. So, try it
again.
[Music]
So, I want you to risk letting go. So,
you let go. Okay? I want you to risk all
of it escape. Just keep the feeling.
Okay?
You okay? Yeah, that's it.
[Music]
thumb.
Good. Yes. Yes. Yes. That's training
only.
Yes. Okay. You can't have You want to be
midfoot at all times.
Yeah, you get if you pay attention when
you get centrifugal energy, you're doing
it via another means which we will use
for the throw, but you don't have it
until you get to that other means and
that's where he gets out of it. Okay,
keep going. You if you chase the feeling
the the pressure on your palm, that's
what you chase. Okay. So, let's say for
example, you're doing this, too.
I'll do the Okay. Watch what's what's
happening.
You're going to be the nugget. Are you
ready? Cuz I said I'm going to be the
Yes. All right. Are you ready? Okay.
All right. Get ready because that's what
you went. Not ready, then ready. Are you
ready? We're going to do the first turn.
Yes.
What did that do?
It mirrored it. Okay. Where does that
hand have to go? To the head.
There's going to be a break in there. Be
ready. Thank you.
You understand? Have the hand ready.
Okay. So, same thing on here. You're
doing the same thing. The hand is you're
like part one,
part two. Okay. No, it's part one. And
there it is. Okay. So, it's like you're
throwing the ball the other hand. You're
throwing the center to the other hand.
You got it. Try it.
Have it up to catch it. Have it up to
catch it. There you go. And then you
were doing the in and out stepping.
Have it up and catch it. So, let me say
this. Have your awareness also ready to
transfer contact on the center. Okay? It
doesn't do us any good if my hands here,
but I want
Okay, I feel the center. I lose the
center. Got it? If you were going to
throw a ball, no one would throw a ball
like this.
I'm looking. I'm ready. I know what I'm
going to do. I know what I'm going to
do. I know what I'm going to do. Okay,
let's go.
This is speed of life movement. We have
to keep them moving. So we have to keep
moving.
Target fixation, right? That's what that
is. I agree.
No, no, no. It's light. You got to get
to the outside of his head. That's
another way I know.
You can't be on the back of his head.
Don't look for ledges.
Yes.
Be ready.
Catch. And there you go. Yeah.
Get ready to catch it. Pass it. There it
is. So, you don't have to grab it cuz
I'm ready. I don't have to rush.
Yes.
Keep your hand flat.
Flat works better.
[Music]
Wait, get your hand ready. Get your hand
ready.
Get your hand. Get your hand. Get the
other hand ready.
Yes.
Get the other hand ready.
Okay, I'm not throwing them. I know I
know he feels down, but I'm not throwing
him. And you guys are throwing him. When
you throw him, you change where you are
on the hand. Where you are on the hand
or where you are on the head. If you had
been chasing the feeling,
you wouldn't change the hand. That hand
wouldn't ever be there. Okay? So, your
team's going to Here's
the knock.
Then again, we reach the hand.
Where's her hand at?
He caught it already. What did you What
were you going to say? It slips to the
back.
And here I You know what I see? I see
Charlie.
You're like you're trying to lower him
or something. You get what I like?
That's That's why I'm like I'm not I'm
doing a martial art, but I'm not on a
martial
The dog mouth my kid. The dog that I
train to kill people is mouthing my kid.
move.
Okay. So, now you're you're letting your
your your spirit.
There's nothing wrong here.
This is so gentle
because I'm going to do something else.
When I feel that,
we know there's a force going that way.
But there's a force going this way too,
right? Cuz it's on a spiral.
Now is where I use that thing. When I
first get him moving, I'm going to do a
short circle inside out. Okay, that's
going to make him fall. So, we go here.
So, here's what we were doing.
You would be doing it right even if you
didn't let him fall. Now, we go here.
You feel a little tightness at the end.
Now I'm not doing those circles. Okay.
Again.
That was all it was. Okay. Try it. Yeah.
[Music]
Better be at the right.
Yes.
So we'll watch Taylor's team. Derrick
will stay the
way I get to watch. You'll see that
Derek if if he's done correctly, he'll
do a tighter turn into it. Okay,
you see it at the end. So, he ends up
belly down. Got Got the idea? Okay, keep
going.
Don't turn around. Don't turn.
That's the feeling. Now see how soon in
the rotation you can get it.
[Music]
That's it. You can get it even even even
sooner.
Okay. There's no Kevin. It's just
falling, right? Okay. You got the idea.
All right. Try it again.
[Music]
Last turn.
Turn.
I'll try to find my footwork. Again, I
don't know what I'm doing. Okay.
So, I'm going to bring her here.
Got it. And then I'm just entering from
here. I catch the centrical energy and
then I'm just entering from here
I think
we'll watch.
Okay, try.
You got to enter with the front.
That's it.
[Music]
Wrong way
to the front.
Got the energy on the outside otherwise
it won't work.
Attach it. Insert. No turn.
No turn. Stay on your base.
That's it.
All right.
There is
pressure right
there. There is the centrifugal energy
that has his center. So I always feel
his center right in this technique
like if you if you
if you like try to pin me down if you go
D which technique is COQ well do you
mean which technique uses COQ? I say I
change your question. So which qu which
technique is co
and then I would go like do you mean
which technique uses coke and I change I
change it slightly. You see and then
what would be my answer?
All of them do. It's okay. No, no, no.
There's something called kokunag. Which
one uses kok nag? Kokun nag does not use
any of the things we do like for the the
uh my my materiality
um displacing his base. I use co to
displace the space but I don't use my
koshi to displace his base. I purely use
the energies that's going on. Okay. And
you still feel like all of a sudden it
got really fast. Okay. There's still a
percussiveness to it. Does that make
sense? Okay. So,
what I'm doing is going here, I feel
just a little outward pull. And the
second I feel that outward pull, I
shorten it this way. But I don't try to
increase it or take it off. And this is
where I want to make the correction.
Don't take it off. You feel his center
from the neck and you're like, "That is
heavy." And you're starting to go around
it by going with it. Do you understand?
And you don't want to do that. So there
is
this movement
against that energy and you have to move
in the same way. Ground the back foot.
Boom. and cut right through it. No
different than this part here. You get
it? Don't look for where is the where
does it stop and it's easy to move.
Okay? You you're not looking for that.
You're feeling where is his weight. Oh,
and I move through that weight. You guys
got it. You got to move through it. And
then you move through it. You have to
move through it the way we did the other
day. Travel that foot. Don't let your
feet point out against each other. Don't
keep trying to take energy off of it. Go
right through the source of that energy.
Okay, try it again.
Better. Yes.
Catching. Get your hand. Get your mind
ready.
Took it off.
Don't take it off. She'll be fine.
And that and that displaced you. But
that was the energy. All you got to do
now is ground that energy like you are
in the beginning. Right.
But that was it. That was the angle.
Not it. Right. You're going around it.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Trust them. Trust. Okay.
Move through it like you're displacing
someone that's standing there.
Go around. Go around. J your thumb. J
your thumb. J. There it is.
Better Sean. But you got to place it
taking energy off. Yes. Yes. But you
keep getting displaced.
You got displaced.
You're taking energy off
base.
Midfoot base.
[Music]
We got close to the edge.
So move or you can do the technique.
[Music]
Catch it.
You have to change your radius.
You feel that? Okay. So, we'll do the
other one.
Nowhere near as percussive. You see
that? It only works because he keeps
doing this and I do this. Got
it? Okay. So, there is a percussiveness.
Boom. Right. But I don't paint it. I
just change the angle. Okay.
Don't push down. Make a tight when
you're in
the front foot
better.
They fall, but I don't aim down.
Don't aim down. Don't aim down on your
hand.
Get it moving more.
down.
Yes. All right.
Same thing. Same side.
Watch the change in perussion.
See that again.
Okay. So, it's not that she's trying to
pull down. It's not that she's overtly
pushing it down. The energy is just boom
like that. Okay? And it's achieved by
the demi. So, I'm going around like
everything's fine,
right? Came around. I catch him. You're
going around. And now when I keep the r
going around, but I change the angle of
the radius by where I meet. Follow the
rules though.
I have to go this way. And again, you'll
see if I go this way, I'm going around
the energy. Go where it's heavy. We use
another guiding metric. Remember,
I understand that
there's a linear to them, but I actually
cut back on the 90. Remember that? I
don't go away from it. So, the tighter
you can get to that where they're
instead of they're they're going like
this way, you go this way, try to go
like that. Okay. Try it again.
with the front.
Better. Yes.
[Music]
Turn deep enough.
Don't push it back like that.
Yes. Trust it now.
Yes.
Don't push him back. Don't push him
back.
[Music]
I hope we inter do that same again. I
tell you, I don't know. I don't know
what I'm doing.
Yes. Now, that's the point you enter.
Now, just keep the feeling in your hand.
Better. Now lose the hesitation. So
there's a gap in your awareness.
Better. Okay. Keep working on it. Okay.
[Music]
Use the circle.
Don't push him back.
Try to turn him on his stomach.
turn him on.
You're going to go all the way outside
and turn on. So, I feel like he's
already
I know.
So it feels like you again that's why I
go like you you can smell it.
Okay.
Where did it go off here?
So there's a time there's a window for
it. You see? So if I stay still
and he's coming in, it's off.
And every is different. So, I have to
move out.
Didn't have to move out on anyone else.
Now, I know why I'm moving out because I
have a a former federite and he likes to
do these weird leans towards the no.
Think about it. Okay. If he just doesn't
do anything, where' the lean go?
Okay, but I worked with him
to and I just the pressure. Okay. So,
his window is different from the next
two from the next, but you should have
felt
that your hand came back instead of
keeping kata dirty. So, if I have my
hand here, when I move, can you move his
center? You can move his center any
direction. Obviously, I need it to move
there. I can't have it move here. You
see that? Now if in my technique
I consider that what he did is resisting
the technique. I consider it a counter.
So now I have to adapt the technique. So
I know he's leaning in past that hand
like you are. Okay. You see that he's on
the inside of the hand. So hence my foot
moves to get the hand back there. Okay.
And um
again like there's there's two two
things that you're trying to train here.
Even though it is kon and even though
I've controlled the environment because
every cook does something different it's
still gaza you see that as long as and
it's in fact it's the only way it could
be gaza is that I have a form I have to
end up with the exact same ending
from a multitude of infinite middles you
see that okay so um that's all that's
happening
Now as the sensei I have the dual task
because I have to get rid of the fear
and the attachment to the institution
right but that's the teacher's job
that's not the no's job the no job is to
make whatever this is doing work you
guys understand that so um
like uh
in most places they would go like you're
not Oh, you're not going in right.
You're not going in right. Right. And
whatever variation of resistance it is.
Okay. Um that we don't do that here. You
make that technique work and then the
teacher will deal with the fear that's
behind or the institutional attachment
that's behind that. Does that make
sense? So, whatever they're doing, it's
the forces that we're working. You make
those work. Okay? Don't go back to other
forces. All right? Even though you're
like, he's so off balance.
Don't go back to that. Okay. All right.
Try.
And Sean, you should just try to not do
anything.
You want that tighter circle.
Circle. Not an extension of the first
circle.
Not a push down.
your feel for it. So here you let's say
you're training here and I go, "Yeah, I
can see you feeling and working on what
we're doing." Okay. And I'll let you
play like that for a while and then I'll
start fixing. Can we do it with Ashi
instead? Right. Okay. Go.
Yes. Now we're finding the
effortlessness again.
No.
Yes.
[Music]
Yes. There's the ch. There's that tiger
turns. Yes.
No, that's an extension of the circle.
Be sure that you you stepped in the
elbow came and now on the head. Now his
balance is back there. That was great to
Kevin.
That's that to me. That's to Kevin. He
didn't do anything, okay? He didn't
assist you nor resist you. He just leave
you let go center. Okay.
Okay.
Now this entire turn is just so
soft.
[Music]
If you take time to think
what's going to happen,
it's going to stop. Can I generate the
centrifical energy if I stop? No. No, I
can't. So, you It's like we think we're
doing it because I'm really to think
here. Well, we're not we're not doing
it. Okay? Does that do you understand?
So, as the teacher, if if I tell you
that they have to keep moving and then I
point to you that you're you're not your
mind is not moving at the speed of light
and now you stop your mind to think, to
me, that's as crazy as I showed you the
technique and you go like
I would look at you and go, "What the
fuck?"
Okay. So, I have to I don't have to go
fast, but I have to keep it moving.
Moving.
Maybe my feet work has to change because
I have to keep the feeling.
[Music]
My cat is freaking out. So maybe I do it
this slow,
but she feels the added pressure. She
feels that value, but she feels that
value too, right? Okay. And then I
didn't even have to do the throw. I can
let the hookah out, but I'm still doing
the technique. Okay. So I have to do the
elements that are prescribed. And one of
them is they have to keep moving.
And I need to get entire circle.
Push it down.
Good.
[Music]
Make sure you're not going to have me
land on you. Okay. So, I do have to
ground the back foot to cut through the
energy. But if now he's going to land on
me, I got to get the back foot out of
the way. Okay, that to me that's
different from this. You see that? It
was like boom. There it was. I got Okay.
Can't get stuck either.
Where's my Chris? Sorry. Where's my
Where's my gone? Where's my
Now there needs to be the tightest.
Yes. And then you got to watch the back
foot in the
All right. This is not It's not easy. If
it was easy, we wouldn't be so so weird
here.
Everyone would be doing this. Does
everyone understand? Everyone would
Everyone's cooking would be like this
instead of just accelerating circles and
getting, "Oh, I'm going to fall down for
you like
It is difficult and then it's made more
difficult by the fact that
my all my reasons for moving away from
these two force engines are ultimately
spiritual reasons.
My spirit is greatly affected
by my supporting practices.
All of this in the end only lands on a
skill
which is relative and perishable.
We the person's big enough.
I have been compromised enough with
overaggitation
and my skill level has now faltered.
And that can be very emotional.
My emotions might be from
back there. I can't get it. Oh,
Right. killing my neck.
I'm becoming reactive. That's why the
training works on the spirit because
you're not allowed to be reactive. You
have to let go.
Just the same way you have to let go
that I'm not getting it.
And the same way I'm not getting it.
Teacher comes over and
making me feel like I should.
You see that?
Somewhere in all of this, there has to
be that warrior spirit where you can
take it.
Yes, those teachers I mentioned this
morning, they they were not pleasurable.
They were not pleasurable to be around.
So somewhere in all this and I get it
all and I can do all this kind of stuff.
Somewhere in there there's just got to
be a cowboy the up. Okay, I
don't know how you want to say it
anymore, but somewhere we going to use
the scient and now the new scientific
word was grid.
Grid.
when I was uh the community resource
deputy for this city
go to deal with the u juvenile crime and
the
and the the uh gateway it was to gangs
joining gangs
Um,
[Music]
and what it was is they're trying to
find the colonel and trying to get to
the seat of it because adult gun gang
behavior is extremely violent.
Um
Sean Sean would know cuz he lived where
you live where the G when the gangs were
heavy duty. Um yeah in Compton. And I
remember one time I had to go pick up
Sean and I was like
you're driving through this place. Okay.
And then um
I grew up in Pomona.
There's a there's black gangs in Compton
and there was Mexican gangs in uh Pomona
and there it was so bad at certain times
that just don't go into that area. Do
not go into that area. You can't. So
that's why I was like Sean lives in that
area. I got to go pick up Sean. But my
whole instinct from the Pomona area is
like you see all the tagging. You see
all that kind of stuff is like you don't
go into that area. Okay. So these gangs
also run the prison and the jail systems
which to this day they do.
So this gang task force is trying to get
early on. Okay.
And they try to give the kids, you know,
makes sense. I try to give them an
activity to do
something to lead them a different way
and give them different mentors.
But every activity sooner or later is
going to rub up against our own
fragility.
So they're like there's there's
fragility here.
We need grit.
you you would go
to symposium after symposium and they're
talking about this fragility that is
there and then
the need for grit.
Now, it was interesting because
no one ever
at one of those conferences
said, "How do you cultivate grit?"
It was never brought up. And I always
suspected
because
it's become a dirty thing.
If you read that book grid and you just
go to the question, let me get to where
she's going to talk about cultivating
it. You're not going to get the clear
answer
because the clear answer is someone
sooner or later told you to stop being a
and held you to it.
Well, those days are probably gone.
and not for bad reasons,
but we can do it to ourselves. We can
hold ourselves to the fire
and be very mindful when we're wishing
our way out of the heat, okay? And try
to hold on a little bit more.
in that in that I told you someone
mentioned in the academy and the recruit
started crying and I got in his face and
I did your department issue you those
tears
then get them off your face you're out
of policy and then He has to write a
memo on the importance of following
department policy.
But it's no different than that movie
lead of their own when Tom Hanks is
going there's more crime in baseball.
What what we're looking for is look the
training is going to be by default
uncomfortable.
The environment is going to be
uncomfortable because only thing that's
comfortable is how I am right now.
Anything
that is comfortable is because I can do
it right now because I am right now what
that is asking me to be. By default then
any any growth has a growing pain to it.
And then by default my ability to take
the growing pain is also inhibiting how
much I progress or not.
There's just no way around it.
Now, a good teacher is going to balance
it because
you can't be broken that way, right?
That's how we got here. No more No more
calling each other No more saying
cowboy up. You get it? No more
teaching people by breaking people.
But we can't get away from this
structural relationship. Progress is
eventually got to be outside your
comfort zone. Your ability to hang and
survive outside your comfort zone is
determining how much you progress and at
what rate. There's no way around it.
So just like the the UK does what
they're supposed to do, does their
assignment, and then the Navia does
whatever they're need to do to get
whatever needs to be done.
While the teacher cannot break you and
should not break you, the teacher does
have to take you into that uncomfort
zone. And you do have to try to hang out
as long as you can. And when the teacher
sees that No, there's no board here.
We're just going to break. Then the
teacher comes back off. Then the teacher
takes you back in. Okay,
there's no way around that. Okay,
so yes, training is uncomfortable. This
is uncomfortable all the way around
to me. Then like I said today, that is
telling you you're trained. That's
telling you you're trained. Okay. The
fatigue and the muscle fatigue and what
day is it? Holy cow, how many more hours
of this till Saturday, right? Yeah,
we're in the right place when we're
starting to think like that. Okay. And
then you you you trust me, I'm not going
to break you. But it will always feel
like I am. Okay. But I'm not.
We've done a lot of allowances already.
There was we didn't do weapons. There's
already a lot of
emotional content on the map. I mean,
why the weapons already did that on its
own on day one?
We pushed the time later. We had more
rest. We had this community meal in the
middle, right?
Trust me, I'm always balancing. But you
got to do your part. Try to hang as much
as you can as close to the fire and
don't ever go fire bad.
I can't just be in my space here that I
can control on my own with my remote.
Okay.
Likewise, don't add to the fire.
Practice release in the fire. Fire
doesn't really exist.
So,
he got it. She got it. I didn't get it.
Who cares?
You're not jumping as high as you can.
You're still working on jumping. Okay,
does that make sense? It's still paying
off. There's still people nowhere near
working on this stuff. Got it? They're
They're a million miles away.
They don't even have a North Star.
I need to go that way.
Worse than that, they think that's the
north star. That's the wrong way.
There's still a lot going on. Okay,
let us point one thing out. Okay.
Let us say
that I'm here and I already feel the
tension in me. And I said, "Well, what
you can do is start
disorganizing this body."
And I said, "Use a very powerful muscle
group to do it. as you start to
disorganize that pressure
by your center.
Okay.
What do you think I'm experiencing now
if this happens to my body? Okay. You're
going to come in slow so we can see it.
Do it again. First of all, what wrong
thing is happening in my body?
Watch again.
The articulation change. Okay.
[Music]
Right. It's no different than he leaned
on you. You have to adjust to keep the
feeling, to keep the organization, to
keep the force tension going. So before
I let my elbow bend, I have all of this
range. And if that was not enough, then
I just moved.
Got it? Okay. So what we were doing
instead is
trying to hold it. And now we learning a
lie that is not conducive to what we
could ever utilize. Okay. So let's do
that just for a little bit. Um so that
we understand what I just said. So when
we do kihon waza you do you make the
technique work as it's just given to you
for whatever the uk is doing in light of
whatever you can do with that force
engine and you will fluctuate between
external and internal you got it okay so
it's not that
it's not that I let him push me
and do you get that I didn't do back
because as soon as I did it, I already
have his center.
He's He's moving. It's already seized.
Okay. And I'm already going to pass it
and I'm already going to do the
technique. Okay. All right. So, try
that. You don't have to stay still. Go.
You have to do the energy equations.
That's all. So, let's see how light and
slow you can do this. Okay.
That's from your downward your
downwardness. You need to tighten the
circle. Needs to keep going.
See the down.
That's it.
Switch rolls if you have it.
Dude, do this.
Better.
Okay. All right. The next thing, the
last point for the deep breach is,
did you notice how many times for no
freaking reason?
Okay. So, what's that saying about my
body mind? I'm very institutionalized.
Okay. The form things for me, not the
inertia or the technique or things like
that. Okay. Um to me that's the same
thing when
I am uh basically I'm not present.
That's what's happening. I'm not
present. Okay. It's the same exact thing
when my I don't move my feet and I let
that happen. You get it? When
or you know like in weapons remember if
there's so much pressure don't don't try
to do that footwork. get some pressure
off of there, then come in and do that
that kind of thing. Be in the in the
now. Be in the moment. What are you
actually facing? Instead of thinking
that a technique is what is going to
work, that's what the institution has
convinced us. Here's some techniques.
Here's your deck of techniques. And then
when you're ready, he's going to pull
out,
you know, the right card to do the right
technique. That's not how it happens.
Okay. Um
same thing like
uh when yes ground but can't ground
where he's now going to break my ankle.
So ground and then get out of the way.
Okay. Right. Make sense? Right. You got
to stay in the moment. You got to stay
dynamic. You got to stay fluid natural
kind of stuff. Um
in a way as I said that ego tripartite
mind is what made the institution not
it's not vice versa. So this is just ego
tripartite mind thinking. I'm existing
dichotomy dichomously I can't stay
present and I can't stay fluid at the
speed of life and my mind starts and my
body starts to become better using the
zen term my body becomes better and I'm
doing things that when I look at it
didn't make any sense at all but in the
moment that was all that was available
to me okay so same thing like like this
to me is better when I was getting on
you on your thinking like right here in
front of your teacher cuz that would
that would be weird. You know what I
mean? Like it would be like it would be
like one of my sons, you know, he's
going to start lighting up a joint right
there in front of me. It was like
something weird here.
You're you're acting like I'm not here,
but I am here. That was your reality.
You see? So the teacher is telling you
got to keep moving. Got to keep thinking
and I'm basically standing right here
and you're like you can't even see that
I'm there. You know what I mean? And you
just start stopping and thinking kind of
stuff. That's all just fettered. We're
just fettered right now. Okay. Um
so try to stay in that moment. Release.
We're getting tired. As we get tired, we
get agitated as I described it. And it's
more difficult to release and
deconstruct the ego tripartite mind
which is why intensive camps are
insightful into us. Okay. Thank you.